[Music]
this is David Rawlings founder of the
London long sword Academy and a
swordmaster with over 25 years
experience today we're showing him
gameplay from Star Wars Jedi Survivor to
get his take as a qualified swordsman
and more importantly a Star Wars nerd
[Music]
oh I'm gonna have so much fun choosing
how to put my lightsabers together
[Music]
be sure to watch to the end of the video
to find out how you can enter our
giveaway and be in with a chance to win
some very cool prizes right over to
David
[Music]
thank you
nope so all these sweeping movements
they are absolutely fine they're
basically they're along Cardinal lines
of fencing so usually you have kind of a
vertical line or a steep line which we'd
call something like a fendente or a
PARTA diagonal lines absolutely wrath
school and bratos this kind of thing
horizontal lines tondos really really
obvious simple things so all of this is
absolutely fine one-handed two-handed
doesn't really make much difference I
always worry about a little bit about
how much the lightsaber techniques tend
to be very very wide very very sweeping
it's not a problem with having wide
sweeping moves they very much keep
opponents at Bay you can get reactions
from your opponents in general you kind
of want to keep your point a little bit
more focused on the opponent and then
still make these same movements
according to what they're doing if
you're fighting against multiple
opponents slightly different you might
want those movements of clearance to
face onto another opponent and then when
you're cutting somebody yeah go for it
all the way through this is actually
something I really like about Star Wars
games in general is that there is that
feeling of wanting to slice through
something so there's a real commitment
to the strike you might take more time
to disabling them from being able to
fight back against you a little bit
first so they'd be a tendency to maybe
cut little bits off them until their
arms dropped and then you can go for the
big finish going for a deep kill is very
very dangerous there was a nice little
point where there's a suppression of the
blade or an engagement of the blade from
underneath usually if we were doing any
form of fencing if somebody was on top
of our blade here we'd hold up against
it so that we know what they're going to
do we don't want to just attach our
blade underneath because they'll
probably hit us through the face so you
have this little moments of Engagement
where you're waiting and you'll either
push their blade aside or you'll wait
for them to attack and push them back
over to the other side and then reattach
from that point so yep that's good
that technique has been consistently
great through all of the Jedi games
so this is a hideously hideously
inefficient way to fence against
somebody who's got a shield basically
hitting somebody who's got a shield
directly in front of them gives them the
distance to hit you straight off the bat
so if you can basically just block
something and stab with it at the same
time any single time attack that your
opponent gives you which is basically
they hit you you can block and stab them
more or less at the same time so it's
not a useful way really of fighting
against someone with a shield people
like Tebow for example and Cavendish
will in general use the shield against
the opponent you'll tend to attack
either the head and the leg at the same
time or the leg to bring the shield down
then attack the head something like this
you'd probably try and use the shield to
inhibit the use of the weapon arm so
that as your Shield is forward it means
the sword is backwards and it means that
the sword has reduced reach
and that's closer to Tebow so anything
where you can get the opponent to pull
the shield forwards in order to defend
them basically starts exposing this side
so if someone brings the shield in front
like this this keeps their sword weapon
distance even if they try and stab over
here it's a little bit of a problem with
them as long as you can get to the
outside as long as you can hit them kind
of here that's good movement and that
involves moving around the opponent in
order to get the action that's good when
we're talking about Girard Tebow we're
basically two different ways of dealing
with this so if the sword comes forwards
at all depending on how the sword comes
to us we either want to be on the
outside of this which makes things easy
because The Shield's not so usable to us
or to be on this side of the sword if
the sword is in this profile to try and
walk the sword away from the opponent's
Shield so we're trying to take it away
from their ability to defend or if they
push the shield across for any reason to
deal with the sword
here now we want to go away from The
Sword we're using that to become a
hassle to this so if you block this with
your Shield proper block it there you go
makes it harder for you to do the thing
with your sword see that's simple so if
I'm using two swords very often what I
will try and do is I'll try and do a
sweep that does two things
so I'll have a sweeping effect that
gives us a Tahoe and a reverse and then
I'll clear okay so we'll have a one here
and then a two so twice we're hitting
high and low
and then we're hitting high and low
again thus we're taking away the utility
of the shield in effect because you have
to defend two things at once does that
make sense if you drop that you're
getting that one if you do the other one
you're getting the other one okay so in
both cases we have two attacks
two attacks yep okay I think if you're
going up against Shields with a light
tape it really depends on what material
is if it's cortosis and I think it's in
chatterpoint they first really start
using it is the idea that you're short
out a lightsaber so that's absolutely
superb you've got a moment where the
lightsaber doesn't work if they were
doing that then that would be great
clearly they're not in this so I think
functionally it becomes the same as any
other sword and shield or sword versus
Shield style because you've got a shield
which is capable of stopping a
lightsaber and you've got to work around
that so pretty much the same as any form
of swordsmanship it's of course one of
the best things that any has any kind of
souls-like mechanic to it anything where
your primary way of staying alive is
dodging out the way of everything and
maintaining distance has got to be seen
as a good thing because everything
relates to the distance between you and
your opponent if you can move around
them great Cavendish talks about
literally trying to get behind your
opponent and then says they won't let
you or they won't suffer you to do so
but that's your plan if you can do it
you always take away their advantage or
you take away their advantage more so
nearly every single sword system there's
very very few that don't will generally
move to one side of the opponent there's
very few purely linear systems so that
movement around your opponent to gain
advantage to gain uneven angles very
very important I need backup to kill you
[Music]
I always think we're a little bit unkind
with double-ended lightsabers as well
because it's very very common for pole
arms to have effectively two ends to
them so although you'll have the primary
end which is going to have the big
weapon on it be a spear be it a halberd
or whatever a kind of weapon you'll
quite often have at least a spike on the
other end of the weapon which means that
both hens have facility to injure
somebody usually people end up using it
like a Pole weapon and that is really
really fairly standard lots of striking
lots of looping you might turn it over
the head and swap hands but that's an
easy place to swap hands because it's
symmetrical and then you just go back to
using it like a standard one-bladed
halberd effectively again it's one of
those things it seems an awful look like
a vanity project a lot of the time and
again still have that capability to use
something
whether it's useful that's a different
thing so it's an interesting thing when
you go from the two-handed lightsaber
being a Pole weapon to being a
two-handed sword effectively
fundamentally you're using it in a very
very similar way you've still got the
two hands hanged you're still hitting
you're still hitting and you might Spike
occasionally you might strike with the
back end but predominantly you're using
it very similar to the way that you
would a long sword and this with pole
arms is not untrue and then it's really
just about how you manage that extra
length around your body without injuring
yourself
quick ly
so it's from a sword pattern point of
view or from a Renaissance martial
artist's point of view as soon as you
start having enclosed environments you
get a lot less swinging you get a lot
more Point work because you're trying to
move around quite narrow things so for
example if we have a narrow Alleyway
that we're trying to defend with a
really big sword such as one that I have
at the back you won't try and sweep it
there's no point you'll just end up with
your sword absolutely snared up on
hitting walls and all kinds of things so
it's very much a stab someone that way
roll against the wall stab someone again
stab someone again so you'll literally
turn against the walls making sure that
your point is going towards the opponent
but it's not swinging and that requires
one high ceiling and two a willingness
to recognize that there's always going
to be these obstacles that are going to
basically leave you open should you
strike them and it's true
generally our principle would be as much
as possible in an environment like that
to keep everybody over one side so you'd
go along almost like a human typewriter
just going like this one this one this
one this one no you stay over there so
there's constant awareness of the people
trying to get past you and you have to
stop that as much as possible so you can
keep all of your opponents focused into
one area and try and press them so it's
kind of like sheepdogging the idea of
driving your opponents in One Direction
so they're manageable don't let them
round behind you foreign
I like to think if you're going to try
and do anything like that you've got two
primary ways of doing it one is to stick
the sword out but the most important one
is to not be where it is when it comes
towards you there's certainly things
where you can try and deflect Throne
Spears and that kind of thing but again
I would suggest that primarily getting
out of the way is your safest way of
doing those things I think this is the
thing is whenever you're dealing with
anything to do with Jedi you're not
dealing with people who are using normal
capabilities so their inherent ability
to put their lightsabers in the right
place it's kind of connected to more to
the force rather than to and I actually
oh I'm timing this and I'm catching you
like this it's kind of an understanding
of where the opponent's pointing before
they shoot the gun and that kind of
blaster and that kind of thing I think
within the context of the universe it
makes sense sometimes when we're talking
about lightsabers I have this slight
Obsession as to whether their ability to
absorb impact is consistent because
sometimes people are just kind of
redirecting bolts back at things without
any effort and then sometimes you have
to bat it back like it's a dentist book
that kind of affects how you think about
how you have to move the opponent's
sword out the way so if a lightsaber is
very very good at absorbing kinetic
shock which the implication is that you
can do with Blaster shots and the
implication that it can do with sword
shots you don't actually if it's similar
to a metal sword you don't have to move
the thing out the way they're really
really good at absorbing shock without
being flung out of the way so it's in
just a semantic point and I never I
don't think it's dealt with consistently
within the uh the Canon of Star Wars
so really an any pad weapon style
there's not usually as much difference
as you might imagine again a lot of
these things are situational when you're
dealing with one opponent you want your
point on as much as possible not too
much difference between that and sword
and Dagger and sword and buckler the
reach of the weapon affects their
interaction with each other so you have
to move them slightly differently
this is nice someone has been looking at
their gardenia you can tell that
somebody who's done this has absolutely
looked at gardinio online and has tried
to work out what the things are doing so
the action where you're driving high and
low with the sword and then double
crossing these are absolutely something
you'll see in gardinio yeah someone's
been watching good in you I would very
very strongly suggest that this is not
even somebody who's just been
taking lip service I think that
somebody's actually watched good in your
work so yep that's a good thing I'm very
happy with that
I like that the idea of just using a
weapon singly and holding the other one
back when you don't need to use both
absolutely superb hold one ring reserve
and watch for your opening good always
room for spinning attacks if you think
about this logically this is one of the
things that Gerard tevo talks about the
idea of a spinning attack is really
relative to where the opponent's blade
is so any action where you're bringing
in your left shoulder for example it may
be safer just carrying on and continuing
that motion into a full spiral this is
referred to as a technique called the
tornado and Tebow certainly uses it this
idea of circling in with the blade in
order to finish your opponent and the
idea being is that you might think that
that exposes your backbone or what it
does is it keeps you safer for longer
and allows you to get closer to the
opponent before you finish them while
their sword stays out extended
hey cop hold on
I've had this since I started
freelancing it's gotten me out of some
bad situations and I figured it might do
the same for you so you may be thinking
does Hema the discipline I practice have
a a pistol manual of a sword and Pistol
yes it does I believe it's Pringle that
does it which is I think boarding
Cutlass or possibly spedroon and
Flintlock if I remember Eileen oddly
enough when you're doing pistol and
sword if I remember Pringle correctly
you actually hold the pistol in a
reverse grip so the Pistol barrel will
actually rest down your arm and this is
a fairly consistent thing within various
different versions of swordplay so in
Iberian swordsmanship and Spanish
swordsmanship they talk about people
having a piece of wood down their arm
that they just used a block and when
you're using a pistol very very much the
same thing just this idea that you're
using the hole of the barrel to do this
I think particularly when you've got
something which is only going to be used
for firing once that's really really
useful the other thing which you may see
in this is absolutely using your weapon
to Parry and then shooting them with the
thing while you're doing it makes
complete sense very very simple and I I
think again that's Pringle so you're
kind of like just Parry shoot absolutely
fine so yep
now when I was talking about fighting
people in narrow spaces this is very
very similar to what you would do if
you've got someone in an aerospace you
don't want to be swinging this all over
the place it's more about doing this so
that you're controlling this narrow
space very much keeping your opponent at
Bay and it's going to be harder for them
to get around that point as well so it
makes an awful lot of sense if you look
at in the context of this you may well
block with the other weapon and thrust
or block with the other weapon and
thrust with this or in this case shoot
with the other thing cool good you also
as a fencing May insist on using the
point but then what you do in the point
is set aside it can mean that you have
to disengage the blade in a much wider
form if you thrust at somebody and they
get in close you probably don't want to
try and thrust them you'll have to bring
your hand back it's going to be an awful
lot of effort when you could just go
like oh look I've cut you ow and it's
fine
foreign
[Music]
choosing how to put my lightsabers
together
this is interesting the guard he's using
seems to be sort of like quite based on
a kilimirot so squadier tester I would
suggest cool little bit montante-ish
ah now there's an interesting thing this
suggests to me that again somebody has
been watching montante rules so the
reason that generally you make this
sweep if you are doing it with a
montante rather than a lightsaber you
would kick the bottom of the sword and
it's really to get it in movement so
that you can carry on and do a swing
from a cold start so if you think it's
kind of like your quick draw but with a
montante it's difficult to get moving
when the point is down so you give it a
kick that spins it into play and then
you crack on with it so I would suggest
again somebody has been looking at
montante rules online in the same way as
somebody's been looking at gardenia's
two swords online which is a good thing
I am happy about this the thing that I
dislike about this however is the idea
that it has drag but it also has weights
if it has weight then it should have
flow and if it has drag then it should
have drag I think this is also possibly
to do with what they've watched and the
idea of making these sweeps very very
dramatic and you can make these sweeps
very very broad because again quite
often we're heard in groups of people or
we're trying to keep areas at Bay this
kind of thing but again you want to be
be in control of the weapon as much as
possible the bigger the weapon the more
you set it aside so you have to recharge
the movement again the more trouble
you're going to have defending yourself
with it you can make quite refined
movements with this and refined is
relative but you don't need to kind of
yank it you really only want to be
stepping towards the opponent as far as
you can reach them with the weapon fully
extended you don't want to be standing
Toe to Toe swinging the thing from
behind you it's not particularly good
use of of space you're trying to keep
people at a distance and that's one of
the reasons you got such a freaking big
sword in the first place
I'll catch every blow
now Montana you absolutely absolutely
can spin with I'd suggest you primarily
spin from the other side so there are
very very much
reasons for spinning and this
fundamentally is to get along the weapon
maintain the cover as long as possible
keep the cover going
striking so the first thing I'm going to
do is quite simply from here I'm going
to strike the weapon down and then I'm
going to wheel the whole thing around
covering and then I'm going to try and
hit you so the idea of this is being
that we have an application for spinning
because here it's safer for me to keep
the weapon down for that brief moment I
tend to like to do a double cover as I
go in so that as I come from this point
and I strike that as I'm going in I'm
going to try and cover this again before
I go you don't need to you can just take
a much much more prosaic view of just
striking this down and absolutely
hefting I prefer a double cover okay so
particularly if we take this from the
point of view if you're jabbing out so
if you slowly extend the spear out for
me just towards the face there okay now
I have more distance to cover now I have
a reason to cover your sworders and
going through now I have a reason to
finish so you see the more extension we
have from your initial attack the more I
have to pursue the whole action going
backwards so again if you jab out for me
one two three
all right
it's one of the things I noticed in some
of this footage and I don't know if it's
consistent doesn't seem to be but
sometimes when you cut on a horizontal
plane you get a vertical plane in the
cut that really really bugs me yep
horizontal blow vertical
that bugged me
[Music]
the turning off of lightsabers is a
really really interesting thing it has
some really really important
ramifications so absolutely if you're
going towards an opponent and you have
the potential for them to block the
equivalent would be to withdraw your
hand and then go back in so obviously
you don't have to do that you don't have
to withdraw the hands so it has a very
much positive aspect if you're going
against someone who is venting very very
defensively you could absolutely utilize
this to disengage from one side chains
through from one side and attack them on
the other disadvantage could be regarded
that as you turn it off if your opponent
is more offensive then what you've done
effectively is you've still withdrawn
your ability to defend yourself so if
somebody was in the habit of pursuing
every movement back into guard for
example you could say that the same
repercussion is going to occur if you
turn the lightsaber off so in the
process of you turning it off they're
hitting you as the blade goes retracts
in effect it has historical context even
though it's done in a different way
I think the edge alignment thing is
annoying and I don't mean the edge
alignment as in which way is your
lightsaber facing but if you're cutting
something horizontally surely it's going
to leave a horizontal line through
something rather than the thing doing
that so that that bugs me but otherwise
it looks absolutely awesome it amuses me
that it seems clear to me that somebody
has been watching videos of historical
swordplay which is lovely I think
there's going to be a lot of people who
really really want to crack into it and
again so much whenever we're looking at
combating games obviously there's so
many difficulties in creating the idea
of blocking and parries but in general
you have to create that through your own
awareness of the environment and your
willingness to go well obviously I have
inhuman resilience in this game to a
degree so I can get away with doing all
this stuff or you can go for the sort of
like the one life attempt and just try
and keep your distance and if you do
that then you'll start using those
sweeps and things in a more historical
way because you're using distance so
I think it looks beautiful
impressive
next time you want to pick a fight you
go through us
before you click away I'm another Dave
and you may remember me from such hits
like the voiceover from the beginning of
this video I just want to remind you all
to be sure to check out the pin comment
below for a chance to win a selection of
very cool prizes this giveaway is
happening all week across Gamespot shows
so make sure to check out all of the
offerings across the week such as the
Kurt Locker spot on and Firearms expert
react the giveaway is available to us
residents only so there will be some
terms and conditions that will apply but
either way best of luck and thank you
once again for watching
[Music]
foreign